高校生ぐらいの時に勉強に目覚めたんです
ね。日本の政治に目覚めてちょっと日本
なんとかしないといけないのかなみたいな
そういう思いがあって色々学んでいくうち
に日本の問題点っていうのは教育なんじゃ
ないかなっていう風に自分の中で思ってい
てそれでどういう教育方法が1番いいのか
なっていうのでずっと探してた時期だった
んですね。大学から学ぶのはま、リベラル
教育。ま、マスコミからもリベラル教育。
自分なんかは他にも正論だったり月刊士の
あとサピオとかウィルとかそういうのも
かなり読んでとにかく本をもうたくさん
読んでシンポジウムにもいろんなところに
行ったりしてでそこで校長とさっき言った
ように初めて出会って理論的なんですねと
思ったんですね。
全てにおいてあ理論的だし漠然と思いがた日本人らしい昔言ったらこの投用思想を元にしたこの教育みたいなのを実践されてる方なんだなっていうのであ、そういう方がいるんだっていうのがちょっと衝撃的だったんですね。
なるほど。うん。
そこからさらにお話を聞いたりとか
はい。
合宿所に行ったりとかで最初の印象とか
なんかどういうものを感じたとかあったら伺いたいです。
生活見って思ったのはいわゆる世間が叩い
てるほどひどい指導はしてないとこですね
。で、そっからま、色々やっぱ調べていっ
たんですね。トスケオ夫スクール事件とは
何だったのかとか、当時の新聞とかも調べ
たりしてそしたらなんか全然違うなと
殴り殺してないなっていうのとかも分かり
ましたし全然なんか意味してるのが違う。
あとは校長もそうですし、浩たちとも話をしたり、一緒に生活して、あ、この人たち強いなっていう、もう精神的にも全てにおいて、あ、強い人たちだなっていうんで憧れはありましたね。
強さみたいなちょっともいいですか?
もうなんだろうな。
強さは正しさなんよ。正しくないものは強くないんだね。だからうちはみんなが絶対俺らが正しいと信じ込んどるし本当にそうなんやだから強く感じるんよね。
なんで信じ込んでるっていうか、
成果が出てるからですよね。そこはなんで自分結局合計で言ったら
年以上働いてたんですけどここで校調もそうだし、この皇師たちからわっと受けたことないんですよ。それはもうやっぱり確立してるというか、強いからむちゃくちゃな理不尽な部下に対して要求みたいなのをしないんですよね。
そこが多分世間だとめちゃくちゃパワハらしてんだろうなとか講師たってかなり厳しくきつい仕事を部下にやらせてんだろうなみたいなイメージがあんのかもしれないですけど、そういうのがもう一切ない校長工事たちでしたね。
合宿所で3年間過ごした時って
使よスクール自体はどういう時期例えばそのマスコミのバッシングがあった時とか過ぎた時あると思うんですけどどういう時とかその辺りだったと思うんですけど
特にま実とかも起こってないので別になんかマスコミに注目されるっていうようなことはなかった時期ですね。
ただ、ま、校長が時々テレビ出演するんで、あの、坂神しの時だったんですけど、あいう時とかは夜中にいたずら電話かかってきたりとか、もちろんそういうのはありましたけど、特にあんまり世間からは注目されてない時期だったのかな。
ちょうど幼事教育、このジュニアスクールっていうのも始まった時期だったので、ま、なかなかすごい勉強になったというか、
あ、過というか、
そうですね、問題時を構成させるのではなくて生徒はいたんですけど、それでなしにこの問題時でない用児、え、小学校低学年までを集めた画宿を例えばこのゴールデンウィークとか
連休の時とか年末とか使って行うようになった時期だったということです。
それがさっき言っただんだんあの効果が
なくなってきたという。それがなんで
だろうと思ったらやっぱり正直期と考える
のが1番人間としての基本ができてない。
だから進歩しない。だからある程度進歩し
ても基準に達するとこまではないというの
が多いのと家を頼っとるからね。うちが
な何とかしてくれるというのがとんでも
ない強いわ。
やってることは一緒ではあると思うんです
けども、多分ヨッスクールっていわゆる
問題ってか社会不適号者が集まってきて
その人たちを直してきたっていう成果これ
は色々と調べたらそれが分かったんで自分
は大学生の時にですね。じゃ、逆にま、今
自分も考えてるのは問題人になった人たち
と違う教育をしたら問題人にならないよね
という考えなんですよ。だ、それが結局
リベラルの教育の否定になっていくんです
けど、だからこれをやってるんですよね。
ジュニアスクールでは問題者が受けてきた
幼児機の教育と反対の教育をジュニア
スクールではやってるっていうことです。
そしたら、ま、反対の結果に、ま、実際
なっるっていう実際このジュニアスクール
にやってきたこの子供たちの今もう1番
大きい子でも20十歳とかですよね。あ、
もう立派に育てますよ。結局ね魂
100までというのは正しいんや。そいつ
を無視してきたやろ。子供かしてね、成長
せんようにあれ成長して欲しくないという
願望があるわね。成長したらろなもんに
ならん。リベラル教育やから。からこの
ままでいて欲しいと親が思っとることが
多いんや。
うちがもう満員でな何しろあの狭い建物の
中にコチも含めると100人おった。だ
からもう頼む言われたって立水の余地も
ないという状態で断るんよ。と断ると親が
しのご言って泣き出してこのままではうち
の家庭は破滅だからなんとかしてくれ入れ
てくれて言ってくるんよ。あんたでも
直せる方法を教えてやる。だからまずそれ
をやれと。ほで治ったら金払わんでええん
だからええやろぜ非教えてくださいって
いう。これはね父親が家の政治を行え
リーダーになれ。そうすると子供学校行く
からは簡単なんよ。今日の夜の朝なおかず
は3万にしますって母親が言う。主役に
対してそれでいいですかって聞くんや。
一言付け加えるんや。そしたらそれでよし
と父親が言う。これは父親が政治を行っ
とるの。人間のように群れをなす動物と
いうのは1番強いやが政治を行うという
特徴がある。だから政治を行った人間を
強いと見る。このうちは父親が強い。父親
が強いから自分たちを守ってくれるでOK
になる。そいつをほんのちょっと続けとる
と子供は学校行くよ。これは逆に言うと投
になる飛行になるという家庭は相対的に
不正の弱さがあるんだ。これが父親がもう
どうしても精神的に弱いていうのおるから
ね。弱いか母親が強すぎるか電界やね。
または母子家庭みんなどれかに当てはまっ
たわ。男の役目というのは人間の役目は
全部一緒なんだ。最終的に種族保存になる
の。だから男は自分が努力して成長して
就職して嫁さんをもらって子供を作って
その子供を一前にまで成長させる。それで
役目終わりなんだ。最後の方やね子供を
作ってから成長させて一生前にする。それ
までの間子
を守らんといかんの。自分の遺伝子へ持っ
たやつを殺すわけにいかん。遺伝子を残す
のが目的なんだから生まれて人生のという
ことは父親が強くないといかんね。で子供
もそれは分かっとるだから電荷のもう
お父さんをケちょんケちょんにやる家庭
これは父親が弱いということになる。父親
が弱いから自分はいざという時に父親に
守ってもらえない。これが不安。不安だ
から進歩しない。この暗証の案は安定や
から。この反対が不安やからね。
まず子供を安定させることにはうまく成長しない。進歩しない。ま、
校長から学んだノンハウとか知識とかは今はどういう風に生かしてるんですか?
今はもうこの全てをやろうとするともちろん首になるし暗証も活動できないんで世間の反応を見ながら、ま、ここまでだったら大丈夫だろうとかそんな感じで今はやってますね。
できる範囲でやんないと潰れたら意味がないですから。それでも、ま、もちろんクレーム行ってくるのもいるっちゃいるんですけど、ま、別に法律違反してるわけじゃないですから。
校長のノーハウとかって一般的にあまり今出回ってないものばかりだと思うんですよ。
うん。
厳しくしろとか言うだけでも文句言う人もいるぐらいじゃないですか。今後塚の要少教育とかのモノーハウはどうなっていくべきだとお考えですか?
細とうん。続けていって、このヨット
スクールで学んだことっていうか、日々の
こととか、あとさっきのジュニアスクール
のことも全て自分レポートにしてるんです
よ。毎日のことをレポートにしててるんで
、いずれこれが役員立つが日本のために役
に立が来るんじゃないかなと思ってやって
ますしね。
[音楽]